the DC universe is chock-full of all
kinds of aliens and gods most of whom
can beat up whole armies of bad guys
without breaking a sweat but who's the
strongest of the strong from
otherworldly deities to extraterrestrial
warriors here are DC's most powerful
heroes Ethan Avery is an American
soldier who volunteers for a program
that allows him to transform into the
Hulk like creature damage for one hour a
day for much of his standalone series
damage finds himself locking horns with
other DC heroes and those confrontations
show just how staggeringly powerful the
man monster is in 2018 s damage number
two Amanda Waller sends a suicide squad
to stop damage and despite a lineup that
includes such heavy hitters as Solomon
Grundy and Giganta damage tears through
them he punches right through the
massive hand of Giganta and proves too
powerful for the power sucking parasite
to drain without overloading himself
eventually Wonder Woman relieves the
squad and damage biter to a standstill
to the Justice League also gets a shot
at Avery and damage number eleven when
among other things damage is able to
easily rip through the constructs Green
Lantern creates with his power ring the
issue leads into a cover-to-cover battle
with Superman in damage number 12 which
ends with Deadman interrupting the fight
by possessing damage so sure he isn't
the most well known DC hero in fact he's
one of the newest but damage is still
incredibly tough with the only real
limit to his power being the temporary
nature of his abilities Shazam the most
powerful alter ego of the young Billy
Batson is said to possess the greatest
attributes of a number of powerful and
revered historical figures in fact the
name Shazam comes from the list of
biblical and mythical characters from
whom his powers are cold
Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus Achilles and
mercury whether he's literally able to
get his powers from these beans or if
their names are just used symbolically
kinda depends on who's writing him
but regardless he more than lives up to
the hype
[Music]
[Laughter]
Shazam has long been criticized as
something of a Superman clone to the
point that DC's precursor national
comics once sued Fawcett comics Shazam's
creators over the similarities between
the two fittingly Shazam's battles with
the Man of Steel revealed just how
powerful
is one of the most famous examples is in
the classic 1996 miniseries Kingdom Come
in this story a manipulated Shazam comes
close to killing Superman less
well-known but perhaps even more
impressive is 1999 sjl a number 29 in
which the Sam strength of Hercules takes
Superman out in two punches to be fair
it's a surprise attack and even Shazam
admits he got kind of lucky but the list
of people who can KO Superman and two
hits under any circumstances is still
pretty short gal gadot movie version of
Wonder Woman is one of the most powerful
superheroes to have appeared on the big
screen in recent years but the comic
book version is even stronger
considering 2017 s Wonder Woman ends
with the titular hero defeating the war
god Ares it may not surprise you to
learn just how often the Wonder Woman of
the comics is forced to endure abuse
from the gods Zeus himself blasts Diana
with lightning in 1987's Wonder Woman
number 10 but she manages to survive the
onslaught she actually goes one further
and knock Zeus on his rear end in 2009's
Wonder Woman number 33 Wonder Woman has
also gone toe-to-toe with the most
powerful heroes and villains of DC
Comics almost always giving as good as
she gets
in 1999's JLA Titans number 3 with
nothing more than her own strength and
speed she single-handedly stops a
massive asteroid from crashing into
Earth Darkseid son Orion has long been
considered one of the strongest heroes
in the DC Comics Pantheon during his
brief time of the Justice League in the
late 90s Orien proved himself to possess
Mike comparable to that of Wonder Woman
and Superman holy with fewer manners and
more ferocity more than perhaps any
other event in the history of comics
2008 s countdown the final crisis number
two proved the spacefaring Orion
deserved the spot on the short list of
the company's mightiest protagonists in
this story Orion interrupts a battle
between his uber villain father Darkseid
and a super powerful Jimmy Olsen in
order to take care of his father once
and for all
father and son wage an epic battle while
the Justice League watches and Orion not
only defeats a villain most DC heroes
wouldn't survive meeting but he actually
rips Darkseid's heart out of his chest -
the Man of Steel was never quite as
powerful as he used to be after the
game-changing line wide events crisis on
Infinite Earths but he's still largely
seen as the indisputable alpha male of
DC Comics heroes after
there's a good reason why he's usually
counted as the hallmark against which
all other DC heroes are measured
Supergirl isn't quite as celebrated as
her cousin but she's proven herself to
be just as powerful sometimes more so
she has every bit the hero he is
she just needs the chance to prove it in
the second season finale of CW Supergirl
for example Melissa Benoist Supergirl
knocks out a mind-controlled Superman in
the crisis on Infinite Earths comics
it's Supergirl who defeats the
villainous anti-monitor although she
does die in the process
in 2005 Supergirl number one she ko
strongman Solomon Grundy with a single
punch and saves the super team that
Justice Society of America from the
villain in the process all in all it's
fair to say that Cara more than lives up
to the reputation of our iconic cousin
okay so Lobo is usually thought of as an
antihero at best and an outright bill
and at worst but he has sometimes found
himself allied with the heroes of DC
such as when he was recruited into the
Justice League in the 2017-18 volume of
Justice League of America and in terms
of his strength well there's the fact
that he wiped out his own race for fun
for one he has also gone toe-to-toe with
Superman a number of times proving
himself at least the Kryptonians equal
and sometimes is better in 1990s
Adventures of Superman number 460 for a
drunk Lobo travels to the fortress of
solitude to prove himself Superman
superior and the Man of Steel ends the
fight by faking his death and hiding
until Lobo leaves if an enemy does
somehow managed to injure Lobo it
usually doesn't matter the main man has
regeneration powers that make Wolverines
healing factor look like a band-aid in
the second season of the sci-fi series
Krypton Lobo manages to physically
regenerate after literally blowing his
own head off John Jones also known as
the Martian Manhunter famously has one
of the easiest vulnerabilities to
exploit a weakness to fire but despite
that unfortunate Achilles heel he's
still one of DC's mightiest and most
versatile heroes although he's not quite
as strong as his colleague Superman
Martian Manhunter shares many of his
powers with the Man of Steel at the same
time however there's a lot Jones can do
that Superman can't which often gives
him the edge in battle a perfect example
of just how formidable his unique
collection of powers makes him appears
in the 2000 original graphic novel JLA
earth 2 when the Justice League's evil
doppelgangers arrive from another
reality to wreak havoc on earth Prime
Jones effortlessly takes out ultraman
that reality's version of Superman after
that fight you can't help but wonder if
Jones could handle ultraman's more
heroic counterpart just as easily
DC's doctor fates is often compared to
Marvel's Doctor Strange though in many
ways the comparison doesn't fit true
both are powerful sorcerers but unlike
strange fate isn't limited to justice
spells thanks to the powers granted to
him by the godlike being Nabu dr. fate
is also super strong telekinetic
telepathic able to blast his opponents
with fire and lightning and he can fly
too of course dr. fate does also wield a
range of powerful spells with his magic
fate has travelled through time raised
the dead and stepped across dimensions
dr. Patz connection to the world of
magic also grants him access to the
elder beans and gods who can cause so
much trouble in DC's vast complex
universe considering even powerhouses
like Superman or vulnerable to magic
there are a few heroes and DC's comics
who would want to get on fates bad side
The Phantom Stranger is one of DC's most
mysterious figures one who prefers to
steer other heroes towards specific
important goals rather than getting
directly involved himself what little is
known about his origin has changed
multiple times over the years in some
versions he's said to be an angel cast
out of heaven for refusing to take a
side in Lucifer's rebellion against God
and in a more recent origin story it's
implied that he's Judas cursed to walk
the earth forever to atone for his
betrayal whoever the Phantom Stranger is
he's not only one of DC's most powerful
heroes but one of its most powerful
beings . he has been shown to be able to
manipulate time travel across great
distances without any kind of external
aid fire blasts of intense power at his
enemies and perceived things invisible
to most mortals perhaps the greatest
indicator of his power is the fact that
he's often forced into direct conflict
with the spectre and is usually the only
single hero able to hold his own against
the vengeful spirits the spectre is a
cosmic entity who and his most recent
incarnations is the physical embodiment
to the wrath of God unlike many
superheroes the spectre doesn't stop
himself for more lethal measures and
usually kills his victims in ways
fitting to their crimes
however the cosmic beam needs a human
host to act for many years the host was
Jimmy Corrigan and Hal Jordan of Green
Lantern pain took up the
antal for a long time - there's no true
limit to the specters powers except that
he can only do what's necessary for any
particular mission for example in 1999
sjl a number 31 the spectre punishes the
former super hero triumph / his cold
heart by turning the fallen hero's body
to ice but it couldn't just go around
turning people to ice for no reason
unfortunately this near omnipotent is
part of what makes the spectre so
problematic one of the more famous
examples is from 1993 Spectre number 13
when he judged the fictional nation of
Latifah guilty of ethnic cleansing and
wiped out the entire country in more
recent years the spectre spark 2005's
day of vengeance events when the
manipulative supervillain at Calypso
convinced him all magic and reality must
be annihilated among other things the
spectre ended up destroying the rock of
eternity the source of Shazam's powers
in both watchman and Doomsday Clock dr.
Manhattan proves capable of just about
anything
nations around the world still reeling
from this morning's announcement
possibly the most significant event in
recent history the Superman exists and
he is American in his appearances during
these stories Manhattan is capable of
growing taller than mountains destroys
his enemies with little more than a
thought and can survive pretty much
anything and he's more than capable of
performing similar feats in the 2019 HBO
series Watchmen but it's this power that
can also make dr. Manhattan so
frustrating as many characters point out
in the HBO series Manhattan could have
changed the world for the better on a
global scale but he doesn't ironically
in spite of his power of Manhattan is
trapped by it this is because Manhattan
experiences time in a nonlinear fashion
he experiences the present past and
future all at once so if you were to ask
him for example why he doesn't wipe out
global hunger with a flick of his wrist
he would likely tell you that he doesn't
wipe out hunger because he doesn't wipe
out hunger the idea that he could change
the future he already experiences never
seems to occur to him check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]